dead launches a piece of graphing
software and it's pretty easy to use
like I've seen a while and um this is
right at the top so for those of you can
go with absolute novices you've got a
keyboard and a journey that you can
choose your regular keyboard you might
type y equals x say where'd they go so
there's a familiar parameters you know
and love for those of us who are going
to start to become a familiar with this
and I suggest that's all of you if
you're using a keyboard on your keyboard
yeah that's right on your honor six
buttons you'll see this little symbol
there it's got the actual technical name
is the Hat so if you press the Hat
nothing will appear on your being but if
you then press two it will become the
index of compound so there's life is x
squared I that way you can do your own
expense laughing quickly you can change
that really easily you can make a y
equals x cubed just as just as quickly
you can zoom in nice and close do
whatever you want now why we are looking
at this is because we're starting will
rather we're continuing on simultaneous
equations and you remember when you
solve these things for example so look
at this one here I'm here right of the
other stuff is just few 2x plus 3y
equals 16 call you this 12 x plus 7y
equals 24 okay what are the lovely
things that I like about theirs on
evidence that it will accept the way you
input equations almost any way that you
want so if we delete this let's go so 2x
plus 3y equals what did equal did
succeed all you have to do is press
enter on your keyboard and then you can
write in as many functions or things you
like so I can go the next 12 X plus so
one what is it eclipse at 26 people
okay now you can see on my view I don't
have it just have to move back out but
you can see very nice and cleanly and
they even color code things for you
right that point of intersection over
there and if you click on it or even
mouse over it you'll see the coordinate
it told you that the solution will be X
equal size y equal to and you may well
have already done this questions this
morning and you're like I remember this
one it's quite you can see now the
reason why I'm highlighting is is
because we said this morning we're going
to move on from pairs of linear
equations so we had a look at when you
got free we're also going to move on
from linear equations to just cover your
questions three at the moment which is
one of the ones that I skipped the one I
want us to focus on first is 3p the
three evils like this X minus y equals
2x y you see I just pour a second dose
type anything yes I just want you to
look at those equations for a brief
moment and once you think about what did
this mean you're going to get some
values out of this when you solve but
what do those values signifier experts
like was true I think we can get a rough
idea of what that looks like there are
no powers is no division so this is
another straight line just like you've
seen before x y equals 15 I'll admit
it's in a form is not so familiar to you
but if i divide through by air
does anyone recognize it now what is it
has enabled to call it's a hyperbola
very good ok so a hyperbola is a curious
shape is curve if not linear so when we
find points of intersection let's have a
look at what happened so you can get rid
of these if you like or alternatively if
you've got them there and maybe you want
to just like hide things because you
want to not make them disappear you can
actually click over here on the left on
those colored icons like this and
they'll stay there but they were be sure
okay so i don't want that i am going to
graph each of these one at a time x
minus y equals 2 and x y equals 15 and
then zoom an appropriately okay so when
you're having a look at this right let's
actually sticks might be easier latina
okay when you have a look at this right
you can do and you can pan and do
whatever you like there isn't just one
solution let's see if it'll do it if you
click on one of those points of
intersection it will actually give you
the coordinates right so now what over
there five comments 3 that's an x value
and a y-value right so x equals 5 y
equals 3 that's one of the solutions and
you come back down to the bottom left
hand corner you can do the same thing
and here's your pair of solutions okay
now when you have a look at the question
oil being asked to do is to solve you do
not have to have a picture already thing
like that drawn and certainly a bit
difficult it is accurately enough that
you could just read it like oh yes of
course it's like through they don't
expect that however two things number
one I'm going to encourage you as much
as possible even if you don't rub it to
sink it right now we haven't worked that
much of hyperbola so far we're going to
do it increasingly I should be able to
say all 50 like it's going to have this
part over here and with part over here X
minus y equals 2 i could rewrite that as
minus y equals to minus x which means y
equals x minus 2 okay i roughly know
where that's going of course i'm going
to expect to put the intersection so
there should be two solution endemic
sense and you can do the same thing for
all of these i'm going to encourage you
to think about okay let's have a look at
let's look at Part C have a look at that
one then why could see X Square + y
equals 4x minus X but now I'm not
expecting you to have precision I just
want you to think you have a picture of
y equals 3x squared in your head can you
imagine it so what's doing you see what
that free has an effect on the whole
thing okay for x minus x squared that's
a little bit trickier but you can
factorize that fear and stress bowing
your head right for x minus x squared
wants to come back
okay do you have a picture for that in
your care okay image the rough one now I
would encourage you to have your
textbook there and then I'm open in the
other window so that you can do this you
can take I think I know what it looks
like y equals 3x squared good and then
what did you say y equals 4x minus x
squared okay does it somewhat match that
picture you had in your mind before and
you see oh yeah I would expect that
there are going to be two solutions this
point of intersection gear and the
origin and then this one up here that is
somewhere in the first quadrant
operational chakra okay so I'm not going
to ask you to draw any of these however
as you look through and i'm going to
write these up to shortly question 3
we're now actually doing the ground have
a look at part g this one here sorry
trample the project what's that go what
is that that is a circle if sensor is at
the origin and its radius will be the
square root of 34 text which is a little
bit less than six okay now this guy left
to it and you're not expected to know
you can solve this algebraically because
when you have a look at this and this
remember how I told you before are some
questions that just looks so nice and
neat there was begging for you use a
particular method what is this question
begging you to do
factorizing is employed but remember
what you try to do again you're trying
to Seoul simultaneous with look I see a
minus y squared here I see a plus y
squared there I think the way they're
trying to nudge me is to elimination
right let's just quickly do it right now
if you add left hand side and right hand
claps both of them what do you get that
get left it on the left what do you get
left wing on the right yes sir you like
oh ok yes now at this point remember
it's something being squared and you can
square negative numbers and that's fine
go to sit there are going to be
solutions okay so you can go ahead you
can put those backing to get why
advantages even if you don't know what
this thing is sexy I'll tell you right
now just lie go back how far laughing
about
really fast oh there we go to be done
just like this guy was a hyperbola and
you can see where it's asymptotes are
you can kind of be kind of implied
religious coordinate axes that x squared
minus y squared Dean has a remarkably
similar shape but i'll let you discover
that when you go and how to play ok